this will be a ui and ux
design tutorial that takes you from
being xero
to a hero in creating a website from the
ground up
we're gonna do this in several parts
first we're gonna have a look at how to
do a wireframe
so that we can make the website design
and sketch it out
we're going to turn this into a light
mock-up using figma
where we essentially plan out the
elements that we want to create
in this design and finally we're going
to create all the images and text to
turn this into a fully fledged website
design
this whole process will be done over an
hour where i'll take you through every
single step
so that if you need to understand how
that process goes the design
thinking the user interface the user
experience between
each part then this video will help you
out now my name is adrian i do videos
around design and development
you can check out my channel in the link
in the description below
and it's a channel that does all sorts
of stuff from design to development
and if you're looking to improve your
skills as well
but this is the free code cam channel
and this channel has
great resources as well for all things
development related
so hopefully this will be an
introduction to improving your designs
in general whenever you're jumping into
any type of project
before we get started make sure you guys
hit like and subscribe and
without further ado let's just jump
straight into it
if you're planning on designing or
developing a website before you get
started it's really important to be able
to do
wireframing so that both you and the
client has a good idea
of what it is exactly that you're
building and how it'll work
in this video i wanted to talk a little
bit more about wireframing
what it is how it works and we'll even
build out a wireframe so you guys can
see the full process
and we'll build this example out over
here if you haven't heard of me before
that's fine i'm
adrien from australia i do videos around
design and development and you can check
out my channel in the description below
but without further ado
let's just jump straight into it if you
haven't heard of wireframing before
that's fine what it is is essentially a
visual blueprint for how the website
will work as well as the pages
themselves
and it also works as a schema for the
functionality of a system so that you
get a better representation
of what's going on it's really useful
and it's really easy to do as well
it can take a number of forms you could
just use a piece of paper and sketch it
out
or you could use your ipad or even one
of the third-party websites which allow
you to do wireframing these days
we're going to take a look at a few of
these examples to see how we can build
our own wireframe
but if you want to get started on your
own you can get started with just a
piece of paper
and if you're worried that you're not a
ui designer and
a graphics designer in general and
you're not too sure what's going on well
you don't have to worry about any of
that because wireframing doesn't require
really
any understanding of ui you just need
the bare essentials of being able to
draw boxes in circles
we're not going to look into colors
we're not going to look into content or
logos or any of that
wireframing is just the way that the
pages will work
and anyone who's doing design or
development will be able to jump
straight into it so
let's take a look at how we get started
by creating our very first
wireframe in this example i'm going to
be using my ipad and i'm going to be
using an
application called concepts which is
just made for drawing
but i'll put a link in the description
below so that you guys can download it
if that's something you guys want to use
otherwise you can use a pen and paper
just as well
the very first thing i like to do before
i even begin
my wireframing and something that i
think is really important is
creating your site map the sitemap gives
your entire website direction so that
you know
what pages you're building and with most
sitemaps the very first thing that you
start off with
is a home page every other page flows
out of that home page so you want to
begin with that
and the very first thing you want to do
is probably write out the
most important pages you have so besides
the home page this is usually things
like the services page
or the product page or the contact us
page
these pages are the core of your website
and if you're doing an application in
this case maybe these are your main
screens that you want to route to
but these are the ones that have sub
pages under them as well
by creating a sitemap just very simply
and visually like this
you'll be able to show and represent how
all the pages
work together if there are some pages
you can branch them out as well
and if some pages are linked to others
sideways you can
draw arrows to represent that in this
example we're going to just start off
with something very simple
so what i want to be able to do is just
an about us page
maybe a features page and a home page
and what we'll do is we'll design these
as
wireframes once we draw out the sitemap
and we might even create a responsive
design for them
but to start off with let's create and
finish up this site map just to see
what we're going to be creating in this
video today
now that we have the site map done let's
start off with
our very first page and the first page
we usually start on
is the home page the home page usually
represents the design that we're going
to be utilizing for the rest of the
pages
and two of the most important parts of
a home page are the header with its
navigation and menu
as well as its footer because that's
going to exist on most of the other
pages
what we'll start off doing is creating a
layout here for the home page and
usually what i like to do
is create it so it's quite wide we can
zoom into it
and we have enough there for almost 12
columns so that if we want to use things
like bootstrap or
other tools to do the layout they're
ready to go
otherwise we can always do our own
layout for the ui
for the first part of this layout what i
want to be able to do is
create a section here for the logo as
well as the menu
and what you'll do in wireframing
usually is
just create basic representations of
these
so in this case i'm just using a circle
with the letter
l there to represent where the logo will
go and for the menu i'm just drawing out
a number of
boxes here with a shaded one
representing the current one we're on
and this will later be filled out with
things like home about and other
sections that we might have pages for
but it gives us a quick representation
of what the header will look like
after we've finished designing the
header we can start looking at creating
the main
hero image and the hero image these days
are a big gigantic image that sort of
runs behind the very front of the
website
as well as near the header and a lot of
the cases these days you'll find that
the menu actually sits on top of that
header image
well sometimes people like to place it
in below
and a lot of these headers as well
sometimes are sliders
so what i'm going to do is in this
example i'm going to draw an
arrow to the left here and the right and
i'm going to
represent this with a number of dots as
well as the text here to say that this
will be a slider image and people will
be able to slide between
different options here now that we've
done
this top header section with our hero
banner we can start moving on to the
next section here on our home page
and when we're designing a website
usually the next thing that you want to
be able to do
is either a call to action or a bit of
information
about a website and this is really well
represented with maybe an
image a large title and some
descriptions about what the website will
be
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a box here with a crosstalk to
represent where we'll place an image
and we're going to create a title
section here which will have slightly
larger fonts
and a few lines to represent maybe some
description or text will later fill in
in this section now that we've got this
section in and we're going to be
creating
more sections out it's good to be able
to label our sections so that
for anyone coming in from a third point
of view they'll be able to know what
each section is
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to create out
labels for each one of these we'll have
labels here for our menu for our hero
banner and in this case for
our about us section that way later when
we need to reference it we can point it
out and if someone is coming in they'll
be able to identify it immediately
now let's take a look at creating our
next section over here
and what i want to be able to do is
usually i break them
into line items because sometimes you'll
be able to copy paste them across to
other parts of the website and also
really segregates them but in this case
when you create the website later on
with the ui and the u
um ui design you might not need those
section breaks but now
we'll just create one more here and in
this case i want to create a section
break
here for maybe something like
testimonials or sponsors
in this example for a wireframe we will
have lots of sponsors to identify
so i'm going to represent a nice big box
here that's grayed out as a
maybe h1 or h2 maybe even a h3 tag here
that'll
represent that as sponsors later on and
i'm gonna draw a
number of boxes because we'll have about
12 or so sponsors and
each one of these will follow that
similar column design that you would
expect when you're doing bootstrap
or you can fit about 12 columns in a
single section
and with this done we'll be able to fill
out this section quite neatly
and we'll be able to identify it as a
sponsor section
now this is really quick and simple and
you can see that
even the line isn't that accurate and
this is more or less done in just a few
seconds the goal
isn't here to have a perfect ui with
perfect
box shadows and backgrounds and colors
it's really just to give a
representation of
how you plan the workflow of the website
to be
when you've got that workflow down you
can move sections around you can move
maybe the
sponsor section up or down or to a
different page entirely but the plan
here
is to give a representation of that
section later if
the client come back comes back and they
only want
three sponsors or two sponsors you can
simply update the layout
and maybe provide something different in
that case the other thing i'm going to
do in here is i'm going to add a button
here
to our about us section and this will
simply be so
that there is a small call to action
there that if someone wants to learn
more information about that about a
section they can go to there
let's take a look at creating a third
section here
this next section will be our footer
section where we'll finish up the
website design at least here on the home
page
and when you're doing the wireframe for
a footer there's usually
a few things you want to make sure that
you add in there
i think that having the logo reset
and placed in there again sometimes in a
reverse color is a good idea
as well as maybe having a contact form
and a site map
so the first thing here i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a small
contact form which will have a shaded
out title with some inputs and a button
to submit
since we want to show that this footer
will have a
darker color what i want to be able to
do is show this visually so i'm going to
draw a few lines here
to represent that this might have a
different shade or
maybe it'll have a dark theme or
something different in general just so
that the footer stands out on each one
of the pages
once we've done that the next section
here i'm going to create will actually
be the site map
now we don't have to give the actual
pages in here i'm just going to draw
lines to represent all the pages we
might want to represent
and sometimes you might want to limit
down your site map just to the core
essential pages but
this is just a representation that will
be having that
in there and finally what i like to do
is display the logo here
last and the logo will also have a bit
of information underneath
and usually the last bit of information
i like to include is maybe the
phone number as well as the email
address so that
if someone's looking to contact their
website service or product directly
they'll be able to do that
immediately sometimes it's good to have
this on the header as well but
at least this finishes up our footer
section
and this means that most of our home
page here
is now done and as you can see we've got
our slider image
about us section some sponsors and a
simple footer
i know that some people like to keep
pages for the home page just a single
maybe height and width where you might
not even have any scrolling
whereas other people might have parallax
scrolling that might go
and reach 20 screens in height but
sometimes that's too much so you have to
make sure you balance it out
now since we're doing wireframing one of
the important things
i think is worthwhile doing is labeling
most of the content
the content we're working with this
labeling is not really for us but it's
more for the people viewing this who
might not be web developers
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select a different color here
in our tools and i'm going to basically
start drawing out
arrows to represent what some of the
items here are
and this will just be visually really
simple sometimes you can do this
on a separate layer so you can hide it
later but i usually like to make it
clear and defined so that if there are
any questions
then they'll be immediately answered by
this labeling
so here i'm going to label that the
contact us form the footer
as well as the business contact
information and i'll work my way up so
that if there are any other things that
might be worth representing like the
phone number and the email address
they'll be really obvious and they'll
stand out
the other thing i like to do is maybe go
through some of the
other sections here as well if we're
going to do
good labeling we need to make sure that
we represent what some of these section
legends essentially are so in this case
like the
darker block here will be a title
whereas these small boxes will be
logos of the sponsors themselves and
this just makes it a little bit easier
to read
let's go through our design here and
clearly define each one of these so
in this example this will be an intro
title
and we're going to have some
introduction text here as well
to represent what this information is
finally let's go through and label this
last image here
on our left and what i want to be able
to do is just show clearly that this
will be an image that will represent the
business
or the information about the business in
a particular way
images are hard things sometimes people
really want to
have the ability to change an image to
fit
what information it's matching and
sometimes they don't even have that so
they use stock photography
and during wireframing it's really not
important which image you select it's
more about
labeling what you'll be doing and where
it'll be laid out and later on when the
client figures out what they want to do
with all the imaging that's when you can
do all of that
finally let's quickly mock up our slider
image in here and just say that there'll
be multiple slides here so we'll need
multiple
images to display this home page and
that finalizes
most of our home page here and now that
we're done with that
i think we can move on to our next
section when
creating websites we do have a number of
different page
layouts and usually what we have is we
have
a internal page maybe a blog page
a contact us page and a features page
and each one of these will have slightly
different layouts and
in this case one of the difficult
layouts to do is actually the
features page this is the page that
really has to promote your product or
your website
so what we usually like to do is we like
to make it a little bit more interesting
with more photos and text and call to
actions to really engage the customer
or the user of the website what i'm
going to do to
create this page is i'm going to copy
over the header section
we want to keep a consistent header
throughout all our web pages so
in most cases i will be copying this
across
what's going to be different about this
page is that we're not going to have
that very large slider that we had on
the home page
instead we're going to have a title
section here and i'm going to define
this
by creating a separate section in here
and labeling it with the page title with
a darker shade there to represent that
h1 element
this will later on be themed based on
the colors that people might want to use
for the features page but for the time
being we'll just keep it black and white
just so that we know that the title will
be in there
for the features page when we're
creating different sections
we need to really visually represent
those
in this case i want to represent the
features page with
a number of large images and large
blocks of text
to really show off what this product or
service will be defining
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
have a large square box here
which will represent the image as well
as a large title
and a description and this will be our
very first service in here
in this case sometimes services have
some bullet points
to show off what they do so i'm going to
create some bullet points in here
and each one of those bullet points
might have a tiny little icon or image
as well and this creates our very first
section here
for a feature image but what's really
cool now is that we can
reuse this to create the next section
for our next feature so what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to just copy
over the layout that i previously used
for the very first feature
and i'm going to copy over the image as
well and in this case i'm going to reuse
them
but slightly different i'm going to
actually place them on opposite sides
this will make the page just a little
bit more interesting without
actually trying to redefine it and it
keeps things consistent as well
now if we have a number of services we
can actually just copy page
copy paste each section down below
once we've done this we'll have a very
simple representation so that
the user will understand what's going on
on this page
let's label this though for someone who
might be viewing this wireframe
we'll show off that this will be feature
1
feature 2 and feature 3. and later on we
can find
images and text to do this but for the
time being
this gives us a clear indication of what
the features page will look like
the only thing that this page is now
missing is the footer
but we can copy that across really
easily so what i'm gonna do
is i'm actually just going to grab the
footer here from
our home page and we're going to copy
that across
straight across to our new features page
and we'll be able to copy this across to
all the other pages that we make we
might not need some of that additional
markup that we created there on the home
page because it's a little bit redundant
but what we can do and i can see that is
missing
is maybe a copyright section because
whenever you do have a footer you do
usually have all that information in
there but
usually also have a really small section
there for a copyright
so let's actually create that and
that'll be just something really small
on f1 size which is usually just
a bit smaller than what the default font
size is on a website
and we'll just represent that with a
single line but we'll mark it up
to say that this will be the copyright
section
and let's also copy that across to our
features page just so that it's
consistent all the way throughout
you'll find that when you're doing
wireframes you can just do this
in a few seconds and later when you're
doing the actual
layout and ui maybe in adobe xd or figma
you can create out different section
components which you'll really easily be
able to add to
other pages but in this case we'll just
do it quickly and manually
our features page and home page are now
done but
right now we don't know how we get from
one page to another page
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
just draw out some really large lines
here to show
how you navigate from one page to
another the first will be here in our
header where we'll design
a line to show that one of the header
items will take us to the features page
and the other will be just in the about
us section where when we select the
button
it'll also take us to the features page
now that we've represented
now that we've represented the
navigation here on our wireframing we
can move on to the next
page the next page i want to create here
is our
about us page and actually
maybe no maybe let's try a different
page let's try doing a
contact us page this one is actually
underrated but it's one of my favorite
pages i know that whenever
i'm visiting a website or a service and
i want to get
in contact with them especially if
they're a local near my area
the contact us page is probably one of
the very first ones i go to because i
just want to give them a call or an
email
so in order to create this let's just
simply copy out
our header here again the contact us
page has usually a number of elements so
the header and the footer are the first
to most basic ones and
since we've designed those already i
usually just copy them across for each
page i do
the other x the other aspects are the
contact us
page i usually like to add in are the
the phone number the email maybe a
form to represent maybe a contact form
that you might want to simply fill out
as well as a map i think a map is
important especially if your business is
local
or your website is doing a local service
and people need to be able to get to it
so let's copy out a small section here
for our title
like we've done similar to the features
page again so that
it's all consistent and then let's
create some of those other elements so
in this case let's create out a
representation
for the map in this case i'm just going
to do it similar to what i did with the
images on the home page in the features
page where
it's just a large box we do know google
maps usually has a little box at the top
left to represent the address but this
should visualize
that and we should be able to add some
markup here as well
to let people know that this will be a
google map that they'll be able to
actually click to
and get directions straight to this
business
next up let's create this section here
for maybe the
contact us information so in this case
i'm going to do a small little icon here
and maybe this will be like a font
awesome little phone or something like
that
with the phone number here and maybe
we'll use another one just like this
with maybe
an envelope to represent the email
address which we can add in the line
below
with these two being the most important
we usually always add them at the very
top
and straight after that some people just
like to send a message through a simple
contact us form
now in this case we already have a
contact us form here on the footer
so sometimes when you don't have those
in the footer you can
add them here to the contact us page but
in this case since
we already have one i think it might be
a little bit redundant to add another
one
but what i might do is just add one in
visually as a representation of what it
should look like if we didn't have one
in the footer and in this case it'll
just be a few checkboxes with maybe a
larger one here which might be a text
area where people can fill it out
with a slightly darker call to action
button which will be the contact form
submit button
and this should finalize our contact us
page
as you can see it's a lot smaller than
our home page and our feature
page but it's because it's straight to
the point it gives the information that
we're trying to provide here straight
away
and in this case let's do some
navigation to show how we'll get
to that contact us page and in this case
it'll just be
selecting the menu at the top right to
make sure that we're browsing straight
there
usually sometimes you also might have a
contact us page somewhere near the
footer
but we'll keep it nice and simple in
this case
now that we have our home page and our
features page and our contact us
page done i think this is more or less
most of our content done in general what
we could do is we could
lay out some of our components here just
so it looks visually a little bit better
if you're doing out wireframes usually
you'll want to do
quite a few pages you want to do
internal pages
category pages maybe product pages and
lots more
and the other thing you'll want to do is
you want to make sure that you also
create ones which might be responsive
this means that you might want to create
one
ready for a tablet or a mobile phone
let's take a look at how we can
quickly do an example of a mobile
responsive design for the home page
because i think that would be useful
just so that the user or the person
viewing this wireframe gets a
better representation of how the design
adapts
when you go down to a scroll smaller
screen size so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to put in a label here for
mobile
version and what i want to be able to do
is
create slightly smaller
a slightly smaller width it'll be what
you would expect for a mobile phone so
it'll
probably be a lot longer than the actual
home page
and we'll probably have to add slightly
different elements
in this case the very first element that
we want to do when we're doing
a mobile responsive design is a button
for the menu
and a second button for an interaction
usually
to call the service or business or maybe
to email them or something like that
we'll add the logo in the middle here
because it'll probably be very small
we'll have to make sure it has enough
room and we'll still draw that little
square in the background to represent
the slider image which will be a lot
smaller
sometimes you don't even have sliders on
the mobile version
and you just have a single image let's
put some markup here to represent
what each one of these items are and in
this case it'll
just be the mobile button which will
expand out the mobile menu
as well as the phone number or mobile
number
depending on what it is let's draw out
an l just
there to represent the logo and have a
look at creating our next section here
our next section was an intro section
which had an
image it had a title a description and a
button
now since we don't have that same wide
angle that we do on a desktop we really
have to collapse this down to a single
column and row
and in this case what we're going to do
is we're going to rearrange some of the
content so it makes a bit more sense
sometimes people put the image first but
there's no context to that
so what you want to do in this case is
put the title with a description in
first
and then the image can follow this these
will all be collapsed
down to a single column so that they fit
in nicely
and they'll flow on based on the
information that they provide
let's actually copy out an arrow to show
that this is the responsive version
of this same content when we go to a
responsive version we usually make the
margins from the top to the bottom a bit
smaller as well as the font size and the
image is a bit smaller
so as you can see this section is almost
the same size as the previous section
but obviously this might work
differently in practice it depends on
how you're arranging the content
the next section here was the sponsor
section
and when we're collapsing down this
section since the
sponsors already are quite small we'll
actually be able to fit about two in
on the mobile design if you were to go
up to a larger size maybe a tablet view
or something like that
maybe you could even expand them out to
four or six items per
row but in this case we'll just stick it
in with
two items or in this case maybe three
items
i don't know three looks like it's just
barring the edge of what's possible
but at least it doesn't make this
section too large
finally let's take a look at the last
section here which is the
footer and for the footer yes the
contact
us form is a little bit in the way so
let's move that out of the way
and let's create out this footer now
since this footer
actually does have quite a lot of
content it's probably going to take up a
lot more space
the very first thing here we'll want to
add in is our contact us form
so let's represent that with a title a
few inputs
a text box and a button and after we
create this we can move
on to the site map and this will be the
next
main column here that we want to provide
and
this column will again have more or less
the same information we could even copy
paste it across
and sometimes you might not even want to
have so many items
you might hide out one of the columns if
you don't want to use them
but in this case i do want to use them
so i'm just going to create this next
section here as
a site map so let's put in a header
section here to represent that
and let's put in a few lines here to
represent the menu items for that site
map
and finally let's create our last
section here which will
be for the logo and the contact
information
so in this case since we're on the
mobile design we could make the
logo here for this footer section full
width
or we could make it half width and we
can create
icons here for the phone number in the
email
and that finalizes our mobile design we
now have our home page with a mobile
version
our features page and our contact us
page and these
are the basic building blocks to create
out the rest of the website
what i'm gonna do is put a copy of
this wireframe as an svg in the
description of this video so you guys
can check it out
i've done lots of wireframes in the past
sometimes
i just simply use a piece of paper and
pen to create them
whereas other times i might create
something in figma or a third-party tool
but the goal here isn't to essentially
use a certain tool to do it
it's more about creating a simple view
for yourself
and the client to present as a plan of
what you're building for your next
website or application
we're going to be looking at creating
the ui for these wireframes
i want to design something which looks a
little bit better
is more professional and it's a closer
step towards building out a full website
design
in this stage we're going to create the
prototype ui
for this wireframe it's not going to
involve any colors or
images or content it'll more be a
version or a next iteration of that
wireframe
where we're creating it in a design tool
like adobe xd
or in this case figma i'm going to take
you through the whole process
of designing this and if you haven't
heard of me before i'm adrian from
australia
i do videos around design and
development and you can check out my
channel
in the description below but without
further ado let's just jump straight
into it
to create our website design we're going
to use a design
tool called figma and this is very
similar to
sketch or adobe xd if you've used those
in the past
it allows you to create a mock-up of the
website design
on an artboard which actually exists in
your web browser
so you can use this on windows or mac or
anything in general
and you can edit this in real time and
even collaborate with other people
and if you want to sign up it's also
free you don't have to pay
anything we're going to sign up here
with our google account and we're going
to create a new board to start our ui
design
once you've logged in you want to go up
here to
drafts and hit the little plus sign and
this will create a
brand new figma file in this case we're
going to give it a name so up here where
it says untitled we'll call this
maybe free code camp website
ui and we can start coding this up but
we don't need any code we can just use
design to do this
let's take a look at the different tools
that figma provides for us
at the top here we've got the selector
tool which will be able to move
different shapes and
items we also have a scaling tool
over here we have a frame and the frame
is used to create
new frames or canvases to create our
designs on
over here we've got our shapes so these
are things like squares and circles and
lines and
other objects that we might want to do
such as images and finally here we've
got our custom
shapes text and moving the artboard
around
finally over here we've got our comment
section but we're not gonna really use
this this is more if you have a group of
people and you need to leave
markup and notes for others to review
for your design
let's start off here by selecting the
frame tool
and on the far right here we've got a
number of options we've got designs here
for maybe
phones or tablets or even desktop if
you're doing a design for maybe
something like a piece of paper you can
do that too
in our example we're just going to grab
the desktop size over here to design our
canvas
i'm going to make a small revision to
this however
for the width here i'm going to do this
to 1980 because this is the normal
monitor width that you ex essentially
usually use when you're doing a website
design and the other thing here
is the height i'm going to also make
this 1980 and we might also
increase this a little bit as we work
through it but this gives us our first
frame
that we can work on and this will be the
home page so over here you can see a
desktop desk 1.
we're going to rename this and we're
going to call this home page
and this will be our first canvas we can
work on
now we've got our design that we did
before
on the ipad when we did the wireframe
and what we want to be able to do
is replicate that same design in a
better sort of mock-up here for this ui
design
so i'm going to take you through that
but before we get started let's
open up and have a look at that
wireframe to see what we need to build
out
what's really cool about figma is that
we can literally copy paste content
straight in there from our computers
we can even drag and drop it so here i
have the previous wireframe we did
and i'm going to copy paste this just
here to the left
that we can use as a reference and we
can see here we build out a home page a
features page a contact page and a
mobile version
if you haven't seen that video i'll link
it in the description below
but what we're going to do is we're just
going to use the home page here as
reference and i've got a separate svg
just for that which we're going to copy
out here to the right
and using this reference we'll start
building out a ui against this so that
we can create something which is
visually just a little bit better and
more professional as well
that we can show off to our client as
the second iteration of our design
let's begin by dragging our actual svg
here
into our page and what i want to be able
to do
is create out each one of these sections
but before we do this
normally when you're creating a website
then you're using a
framework for the layout maybe something
like bootstrap with rows and columns
so let's create a little bit of a grid
layout here
there's an option here on the far right
called grid layout
and i'm just going to select one in here
it does a default 10 pixel by 10 pixel
grid
but we want to customize it to be our
own so in this case
i'm going to select columns and fold
columns i'm going to do
12 because that's what normal bootstrap
uses
of course the width for this is a little
bit too much
so i'm going to reduce it down and we're
going to select a gutter of 15 pixels
and maybe a width of about 80 or 90 here
just to represent our columns of course
this can
change depending on what you're using
but this should just get us started
the next thing we'll want to do is
create here
our section for the slider image and i'm
going to select the box tool here at the
very top
left and we're going to drag and pull
down to the bottom right here a nice big
box
this is a little bit too big right now
so i'm going to reduce this down to
maybe 800 pixels
and we're also going to give it a
slightly lighter tint
so here in the far right in the fill
section
we're going to change the c4c4 hex color
to just eee and that should be a lot
more visible now
the next thing i want to be able to do
is have a look at creating a
menu and to do this we select this
box tool once more and we're just going
to drag it and follow
our columns here we might not use all
the columns we might just use
most of them here and we'll give this
maybe a height
of about 60 pixels so let's update this
here on the far right
the next thing we're going to do is
select the box tool but drop it down
and select a circle and for this circle
this will be the logo so i'm just going
to
pull it in here from the top left and
this
might just pop in here as two columns in
width with one column here having a
space between our menu
and our logo and it'll be another circle
in here so we can see that a lot better
let's
take out the grids here so we can see
these items a little bit
clearly here we go and we can see we've
got our logo and our menu placeholders
there
for our logo i'm going to select the
text tool here
and i'm going to type in logo just
anywhere here on the page
when we zoom in now to maybe say 75
let's just do that here at the top right
and have a look we can
pull this straight here towards our logo
and our circle
and we'll make this a little bit bigger
i'm going to make it 24 pixels maybe
even
48 pixels and i'm just gonna put this
right on top of the circle i'm gonna
give it a slightly lighter shade so
maybe something like
999 and it'll just go over here we can
add it in later
the other thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to group these two items
right now this is just called an ellipse
and a logo for text
but i'm going to select both of them and
hit ctrl g
and this will now be a group and for
this group i'm going to label it
logo just so that we can be able to use
this later on
if we do we can always expand it out
here on the left or double click on it
to access the items
inside now for the menu i want to be
able to do the same thing
so what i'm going to do is grab the text
item here
and i'm going to put in a few different
pages
since we know which pages we want to use
it'll be pretty
easy we've got the home page which we've
already built
we'll have an about us page we'll also
have a features page and maybe
we'll have a contact us page
let's create one more item in here and
normally the
final item we might have is something
like pricing
or maybe purchase and this is usually
on most websites just so that it takes
us to where we need to go
now that we have all the menus done
all we need to do is space them out
equally
because right now they sort of don't
have the correct amount of spacing
there's a few ways we can do this we can
pull one of the items from the very
left here and we can do one two three
four
which is 40 pixels from the left then we
can apply the same
to the boundary so we'll do one two
three four here
but since this is padding from the left
here we'll do another one two three four
so that should be about 80 pixels then
when we do the next unit over here we
should be able to apply the
same amount of padding figma actually
has
some tools here that automatically tell
you how much padding is applied
so here we had 82 so i'm just going to
reduce that by 2 pixels for both of
these
and that should be just about right so
if we have a look now it's 80 and 80.
let's move this down as well so it's on
the same line height
and we can then browse over here to the
purchase one
also put in 80 pixels so here is 80
here let's double check that's 80 as
well it doesn't seem to be 80.
let's have a look 79
80 80 and this one over here will be 80
as well
then we can move this menu in just a
little bit
so this should be about 80 pixels as
well from the far right
and finally we want to highlight our
active item which is the home page
so i'm going to copy over this box and
i'm just going to create another one on
top here
and this one will have a darker shade so
maybe something like 666
and we're going to invert the color here
for the home
so that'll be white on dark gray
now with that done we have our menu more
or less complete
we can reduce the height a little bit so
instead of 80 we could
push it down to maybe 60. let's actually
move it down just a tad here
we can see that it's fitting in quite
nicely there
the next thing we can do is have a look
at creating our slider here
because right now it doesn't look like
much of a slider so
in order to do that what i'm thinking is
maybe create a
couple of those arrows here on the left
and the right
now there's a few different ways we can
do this we could go to
font awesome for example we go chevron
left here and this is a icon here we can
use from font awesome we can
actually download the svg in here when
we do we can
literally drag and drop it straight into
our design over here
right now it's a little bit too big so
i'm going to resize it down just a tad
maybe down to about say let's see
we'll lock in the resizing tool here and
i think for the width i'm going to do
40 pixels and the height can stay at 64.
and that's just about right and we're
just going to center this here
to our slider we'll also give it about a
40 units there from the left
and we'll also reduce its color so here
on the right
i'm going to give it a 50 opacity just
so that it's not
fully black we could even reduce this
down a little bit more
maybe at 33 percent and that's just
enough to give it a bit of a great tint
but it'll also blend into the background
later if we add an image in here
we can copy over the same chevron and
place one here to the far right
i'll give this another 40 pixels and
i'll also rotate it so it's pointing to
the right side
and finally we might add a few little
dots here to the bottom of our slider
which might be about 22 pixels in width
and height
and we'll copy them over just so that
they can represent the slides themselves
and which one is the current active one
so let's do that just over here and we
can give them about
10 pixels of space in between
and with that done i'll also color in
the very
primary one here with that dark gray
tint
so that's our slider done for our home
page it's also our logo and our menu
done
and this looks pretty accurate comparing
with our slider image
the only other thing we could do in here
is maybe some hero text
so in here i'll just put in hero title
and i'm going to give it a slightly
larger font size maybe like
72 pixels will be just about right
and maybe a heavier weight at maybe bold
hero title example can be our primary
text here
if we open up the
the frame here with the columns and make
that visible we can make sure it's
aligned properly here to the left
and i'm going to copy this over and make
a smaller
one here and this one i'll give it a
regular weight
and this can be a hero sub
title description
beautiful we'll also give this a
slightly
uh slight opacity at maybe 66
and we can turn off the grids over here
now so we can take a look at that
and in terms of a slider this is pretty
good i'm pretty happy with this hero
banner slider and navigation
we can take a look at creating the next
section in our design here
and the next section if we take a look
at it it's actually doing the about us
section where we've got an
image on the left we've got a title a
description and a button
and this should be pretty easy to do
using our column design so let me pull
this
in here to the right so we can start
working on it
so i'm going to copy over this entire
section that we had here for our hero
and create this one with a slightly
lighter tint maybe something like f1 f1
f1
this way we can see that we do have a
height to it
but we're going to work within the
bounds of that height just so that we
don't make
anything too large or too small but it's
consistent with all the other sections
what we want to be able to do is open up
our rows here
and for our rows i want to be able to
see them
and i want to work within the bounds of
them and by rows i of course mean
columns but
you get the idea what we're going to do
is we're going to create a square here
to represent the image and this will
span about four
columns i'm just going to center this
inside this section right over here
and the next thing i'm going to do is
create a description section where
i'm copying out the hero description and
pasting
it just here on the right with maybe a
one
column gap i'm going to bump this
height up a little bit so that it's got
less margin between the title and the
description
and i'm also going to copy out this
description
create another one here which might be
24 pixels in
width or font size anyway and we're
gonna expand out this section
let's jump in on the lorem ipsum website
here
and let's copy over our favorite bit of
text
we're going to paste it here in the
description and
anyone who wants to can edit this in the
future but it gets our description up
and running
i don't want so much content so i'll
remove some of it
but below here if we take a look we are
almost getting the design
the same here as our wireframe what we
need though
is a button so i'm going to copy over
this image
i'm going to pull it here over to the
right and i'm going to give it a height
of about the same as the menu which was
60. we're gonna reduce the width a
little bit here
and we're going to add some text here to
put on top of the button
here we go and in this case i'm going to
do something like
read more this is pretty standard the
only other thing i might do here
is bump up the text just a little bit to
maybe
28 28 does just about right
let's resize the text sizing box over
here
and let's also center this read more
section
this button here i feel like it'll do a
lot better if it's a darker shade
so i'm going to make it a 666 with the
color for the readme being a white color
and that way you can stand out just a
little bit more
so that way we've got this section done
here and it's starting to look pretty
good
i'm pretty happy with it so far and i
don't think we need anything else it
gets us started for this introduction
section
i only think that the title here for the
hero is a little bit too large because
we've already used this
large size on the hero image so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to bump this
down
just one lot of units to maybe 64 pixels
or maybe even
48 pixels 48 might be a little bit too
low so i'm going to reduce it down to
say
60 and this one over here maybe 236
that way they don't look a little bit
too overwhelming they still fit within
the confines of this section
but they don't overwhelm you similar to
how the hero section is
meant to be a lot larger now let's
take a look at this section without any
grids
implemented i'm gonna re turn them off
over here
and i'm also going to take off this gray
color for the background of this section
and we can see that it's looking pretty
good
if we take a look at our original
version here we can see that we have
quite a bit of padding here
from the top to the bottom that's almost
200 pixels
but we could reduce that in the future
it's more about keeping this section
similar i'm going to copy over this
section but
before i do uh we should really have a
look at
how we're doing the grouping on the left
here because right now it's a big
mess and we don't know what anything is
so what i'm going to do is
grab the common items in this section
by shift selecting them and i'm going to
group them
with control g and in here i'm going to
do
about us section this will be a clear
indication of what this section is
because right now we're not too
sure in here we can give some more
labels as well
so this might be the image over here for
the readme
i'm going to group that as well and
we'll do this as read
me button and then finally we've got one
more
rectangle here and we'll call this bg in
case we do want to add a background
later
if you're feeling particularly ambitious
you can also reorder these things
so they make sense logically so for
example the title might go first
the description second the text and the
button last with image here being
first being on the left of these columns
and that's our section done here the
other thing we can do is actually
lock it into place so that way we can't
select it or move it about anymore
this will be a good idea to do as well
here for this
main hero section so i'm going to grab a
lot of these
elements here so that we can group them
all together
that way they can exist as they need to
so we'll call this
hero section the other thing we have to
do is the same here for the menu
so i'm going to group these and call
this menu and we'll pull this
up above our hero section and we could
even pull it inside the hero section
but normally since we'll be using this
menu outside for other pages
it might be useful just to have it
outside the same goes here for the logo
so i'm going to pull that
outside as well that covers most of
our section here for the hero and for
the about us section so let's actually
lock these
into place so we can begin working on
the next section i'm also going to
increase the height of the homepage here
to 250
or 2600 pixels and this will give us
room to
create the section here for the sponsors
so what i'm going to do is copy our
about us section
and i'm gonna drag it in here below but
i'm gonna make a few changes to it
so over here if we have our button for
readme
i'm going to take that out the one here
for the description i'm going to also
remove that
we'll only be left with the hero title
and subtitle
i'm also going to put this up all the
way to the top of this section
and i'm going to try and center these so
that they exist
right in the middle of our page if we
move it across we should
have figma essentially tell us by a red
border when it's ready there
finally i'm going to enable our columns
here again so that we can see them
and this image that we have here for our
design we're going to shrink this down
to be essentially
two columns in width and we're going to
copy this across so let's actually copy
this in here and i'll keep copying this
across until it spans
all of our row here
and these will be our sponsors now you
can see that we've
fit most of them in here and i think
that's pretty good
the only other thing i want to do with
this section is
possibly give it a slight background tin
i'm going to grab the same tint we used
here for our header but now that we have
applied a bit of the tin
we are going to have to expand it out
just a little bit
so that the title section there has the
same sort of
height as it does in the other section
so i think that's about
200 pixels let's move all of these down
and that's looking a little bit better
there since
this isn't a hero title example this is
about
us i'm going to rename all this rename
this to about us example
and about a subtitle
for this section here i'm going to do
this as the sponsors
example and the sponsor's
description let's center this and
since this is a line left in terms of
text there's a tool here that
gets us to align at center so i'm going
to apply this both to the title
and the subtitle and i'm going to move
them again into the center so that
they're working properly
and that should be just about there
we also want this to have a little bit
less padding
from the bottom there so i'm thinking
just about 200 pixels
and that's just about right but it feels
like it's too
many pixels i'm gonna maybe make it only
a hundred
and that's about a hundred there so
that's
pretty good there for our sponsor
section i'm just gonna move the images
up
just a tiny bit i'm gonna redo how
centered this is so that it just does
look centered so
that's all done and we can move on to
our final section which is actually our
footer so we're almost done for this
design
and it's starting to come out pretty
good let's
remove the columns over here to have a
look at the sponsors section
and the thing about this is that if we
take a look at the batter section
it's got about 200 pixels of padding
there from the bottom and the top
but for this sponsor section it's only
about 100 pixels
and this is because there's less content
so it's got a bit
less room to breathe there simply
because it's not overwhelming with
content the more content
you normally put into a design the more
padding you want to make sure that
you're adding in so that everything
stays consistent
in here i just want to make sure it's
just about 100 pixels so that's looking
good
now for the footer a footer design it
normally has a much darker tint to it
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
copy over this home
box that we created earlier i'm going to
use this as the baseline for our footer
over here so let's actually cut and
paste this in here below
i'm also going to make it a little bit
bigger here so i'm going to expand this
out just here to the bottom
and that should get our footer section
ready
now if we take a look here in our
wireframe we're using a logo
a contact form and a site map since we
already have a logo here i'm gonna
actually copy this across and we're
gonna paste it here below
we can see that that automatically looks
okay
the next thing i want to do is this
rectangle i'm just going to group it in
its own section here
and i'll call this footer bg for the
time being
and the logo i'm just going to move in
here and we're going to group this whole
thing as
footer for this section i want to
open up the columns here again so we can
see what we're working with
and we want to design something around
these columns
so if we take a look at the actual svg
here that we created before and how it's
designed we can see
that we have the three columns here so
the first one will take up four columns
the next one will take up another full
column so let's
let's do that over here i'm just going
to
block them out so i can see how much
space they're taking up
and there we go so those are the columns
we'll be using so
in here i want to put my first title so
i'm just going to
apply that possibly let's move the logo
here to the left
and let's put in these titles so for the
title here
i might copy over this large text that
we use for our sponsors and just
drag it in below we'll move it up here
into the group
but instead of being a black color i'm
gonna make it a white color
just so that we can see it properly so
here i'm just gonna
select white and for the description
here i'm going to set that to white as
well
i'm going to pull this in over to the
left so it's aligned left and i'm also
going to give it some padding here from
the top
and this is about 10 pixels worth of
padding and i think
that sorry 100 pixels worth of padding
which i think should be just enough
here i'm gonna write in contact us and
let's just set this to be a line
left and we'll move this back over here
to the left
and here i can write something like send
us a
message i'll also align this to the left
here and we'll make sure that it just
starts off here near the column
so that's looking good the next part
that i want to do is
copying this over and creating a bit of
a
site map so here i'm just going to type
in site map
and all our pages
and finally we've got our logo over here
we do also want some
contact information below our logo so
i'm just going to copy over this
subtitle text and in here we're going to
put in a phone number
in this case i'm just going to make one
up but that should get us up
and running the only other thing that we
have
in here is actually a little icon there
for the phone
so i'm going to jump into font awesome
to get that
over here i'm just going to type in
phone on their website
and it should pop up with a few icons
here i'm just gonna grab the very first
one to download
and i'm gonna just drag and drop that in
we'll set the color here to be white and
i'm just gonna resize it down here to
about 36 pixels and we'll just align
that
just to the left of our column here we
can pull in the phone number just a bit
and that looks good we can then copy
this across
and we can do another one here and the
second one might be the email address
so here i'll type in email at
address.com
and we can fill that in later but we'll
probably want an icon for that too
so over here let's do envelope and i'm
going to probably select the very first
one over here as well
and i'll just click to download that one
i'll see if i can drag and drop that
in and that has not appeared at all i'm
not sure what happened there
but that's okay we'll just delete this
phone over here
and i'm gonna drag it in once more and
i'm gonna set the height
and width here to 36 pixels
great we'll also change the color here
to be white
and i'll just drag that here next to the
email so we've got the email and the
phone now done
let's do the contact us section now for
this section
we'll have some forms here so as a
form input i'm going to actually create
a box here
and i might give it a white color this
will represent the input
and i'll just increase the height here
to about 60 so it's consistent with the
rest of our buttons and stuff
and i'll also put a placeholder text in
here
for this maybe i'll write something like
full name
and we can make this a little bit
smaller maybe 24 pixels
and we'll also give it a slight
shade so maybe a 50 opacity will apply
then there is our first input i'm going
to
copy that across and create a second one
here
and for this second one i'll do your
email
and we'll maybe create one last one here
and this last one we can actually give
it
one more column for the sizing here and
a little bit more height maybe 120 in
this case
and what this can be is our message
so let's pass that in here finally we'll
need
a button people can click on so i'm
gonna copy over this input one more time
and this time we'll drag it here in
below and i'm gonna
reduce this width here to two columns
and i'll
type this in as maybe submit now we want
this button to stand out a little bit we
don't want it to be the same as our
inputs
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give it a nice dark
color not exactly black but like a dark
gray
which is a 333 in the hex colors and
we'll change the font color here
to be white at 100 opacity so that way
we can see it standing out there
so that's our contact form done that
looks pretty good
let's fill out our site map over here
i'm going to copy
the full name text over here and this
can be
used for our links i'm going to set this
to a full
white 100 opacity color and in here i'm
just going to
put in a couple of links this doesn't
have to be
anything special just copy out the same
links that we had on our
header here but uh what we can do
is maybe we can play around with the
sizing just a tad because it does feel
like it's a little bit too small
but once we do i can see that that's
looking much better as we have more
pages we could fill this out and we
could even embed it
indent it if we had sub pages but this
is enough for our footer design here
the only thing we're missing now is a
copyright section
so i'm going to actually create this at
the very bottom here
and i might give it a 100 pixels of
height here
and we'll give it a darker shade so what
i'm thinking here is maybe the
333 color that we use for our submit
button
and let's copy over maybe our text here
for our subtitle and place this above
the element
and what we want to do is just put in a
generic copyright
message in here so something like
copyright 2020
all rights reserved
company name beautiful we can even put
in a copyright icon for that but
for now i'm not going to worry too much
about it it's also a little bit too big
copyrights are usually a lot smaller so
i'm going to reduce this to
24 pixels and i'm also going to
center the text and center the
positioning here so that it's exactly in
the middle of our page
so that looks much better now with our
footer done we're mostly done with our
home page and
this has actually turned out quite good
we
can have a look at all the elements here
and what we can see
is that in terms of the spacing the only
issue i have here is maybe this about us
section
is just a little bit too big i'd like
maybe
for there to be about 100 pixels from
the top and the bottom because that 200
is almost too much
so what i'm gonna do is actually move
this section up a little bit
and we'll make sure that it's a hundred
pixels from the top
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
and this square here i'm gonna resize it
and just go
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
beautiful and then we can move all the
other elements
up here so that is looking
much better now let's just make sure we
grab all of these and move them
up so if we have a look now we have
consistent spacing between
each section we've got our header and
footer and we just resize our
our frame here a little bit just to cut
out the bottom bit here
now that we're finished with the home
page let's
take a look at our original wireframe
and how
it's been applied to our ui over here
originally we
had our slider image here and we've
applied that with our logo and our menu
here at the top and that's come across
quite well
we added some awesome icons here on the
left and the right
but we've also added in some text here
and this is pretty important because a
lot of the times when companies do
have images they also want to carry
across a statement
and this will do that in terms of the
next section here for about us we've
followed the grid structure here of
column design
and we've made sure that everything is
consistent so that later if you want to
do a responsive design each one of these
columns can break into a row
and for the sponsors section we haven't
added 12 sponsors in there we've just
done
six usually sponsor images are pretty
big
and if you have them really small you
won't be able to see them properly
this way by just having six right here
they fit into that column design a lot
more neatly
and if we wanted to we could add more
but they can also collapse down much
easier too
and finally we have our footer over here
where we've had a contact us form
a site map a logo and some contact
information
there's room here for growth as well if
the site expands out further
or at least these are the basics of what
you would expect in a footer as well as
our copy right there at the very bottom
the design for any website or app is one
of the most important steps before
developing it
we all know how hard it can be to change
things down the track and this is why i
always like to measure twice and cut
once
we've been looking at this series where
we've been putting together a
website design we've done the wireframe
for it as well as a small ui prototype
in this video we're going to be doing
the full mockup for this website design
this will involve adding in actual
pictures and content and other things to
flesh it out
here are the items we were working on
previous videos
here we can see the example of the
wireframes we've created for a home page
a features page and a contact us page as
well as a responsive mobile menu
if we go across here we can see how in
the next video
we actually built out a small ui
prototype for this one here we've got a
bit more
of a idea of what the pages will
actually
look like we're going to use this as
reference and
copy this out to create our actual
mock-up in today's video
this will involve filling out real
content which will mean that we probably
need this website to have some sort of a
meaning or a real logo with
an actual bit of content here now i'm
doing my own sort of a website recently
it's called enhance ui and it's going to
be designed for
developers so i think this will be a
perfect example where we can fill out
some content
and build it around that sort of a brand
the first thing i'd like to be able to
do is pull in a logo over here
right now we just have a placeholder for
one i've actually got a logo ready to go
so i'm just gonna drag and drop it right
into here and
we're going to make it around the same
size here
and this will just fit in nicely there
the other thing i want to be able to do
is change the background now we're
working with
a much darker shade here so this
gray here probably won't work very well
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this layer here
and i'm just going to grab the
background color of 1e1e1e
which is what we're using for this
example i'm also going to grab the title
and subtitle here and i'm going to
select both of these to
have a white color because right now
they're not very visible
and this gets us started with this
section over here
the next thing i'd like to do is add a
bit of a background to it
so here we've got a few different
options we could add maybe
a background color or a background image
and in this case i'd like to be able to
grab
a background image for it so i've got
another image which i've gotten ready
here and i'm just going to drag it in
we're going to move this layer just
beneath our rectangle here
and place it in here just like this and
this should fit in
quite nicely now we've got an example of
how
a background image and some text here
can fit in
very well for our header section and all
we really need to do is clean up maybe
the menu
and the title here so for the title bit
i'd like to write in something like
design for
developers and for this learn
how to enhance
your website so there's our title
and description and the only other thing
i want to do is maybe throw in an image
of a book in here so
in this case i've got another image
ready to go with the book that i'm
working on for this website which is
just over here and it's already got a
bit of a box shadow which we can apply
and as we can see these elements have
fit in quite nicely and give us an
example of what this will look like
the only thing left here is this menu
and right now we can't see it very well
in this gray sort of a format so what i
might do is double select
it here and change the background color
to either black
or white depending on what works right
now it feels like neither of them work
so i might play around with a few
different colors the blue here that
we're using for the side does look
pretty good
so i might use that blue here with the
white for the current item
we might make the text here a black
while the other text items here we might
make a white color
and that stands out quite nicely the
only other thing i feel like we're
missing is that maybe
this logo here is a little bit too big
so i'm going to reduce it down just
a tad so it's almost the same size as
our menu over here
and that pretty much does our uh image
here it's it's
okay because we've got this slider
section here and we might not be using
this so i
i could change this to a white color and
we might leave it for the time being we
might have a look at doing other sliders
in the future here
but i think that's enough to get us off
the ground
the next bit we have here is this about
us section
and we've got a small area here for
images
what i might do for this image is just
put in a placeholder for the book once
more
so in this case i might do something
like
grab this design image that i've created
as part of the book
and place it in here by doing so we
almost don't have enough room but what
we could do is we could
move this image next to the rectangle
and mask it so i'm just going to do that
i'm going to select both of them
i'm going to do use mask and then that
fits in quite
nicely in there there we've got an
example
of one of the pages from the book and i
think that
seems to work quite well the next thing
we want to do
is for this about us section we want to
give it a bit better of a title
since we both have some content here
for a main title and a subtitle what i'm
going to do here
is just copy in a main title and then
add a subtitle which gives a little bit
more information
for it finally we might also give it a
bit of a description
so i'm just going to paste in a bit of
content here to get us started with that
we've got this section almost done the
only other thing we might do
is make it a little bit bigger so i'm
going to drag down some of these
elements here so that we have a bit more
room
to play around with so here i'm just
going to move this
more button down just a tad and for this
section here
i might also highlight some of the
prominent areas like
for example my name over here which i
might want to stand out so i'll also
build that
and otherwise that looks pretty good now
with that done we might move this button
back up a little bit
and we can also increase this mask a
little bit so
for this i'm gonna grab this out and
just
increase the height here at the top and
at the bottom and now that looks like a
full
on page the only other thing here is
that this button
is still gray and it doesn't seem
consistent with the overall
theme with this theme we've got a bit of
blacks and whites and blue so i'm going
to keep that consistent throughout the
design
so this takes up our slider here and our
about us section and we can move
this sponsored and site map section back
up
now previously we did have a sponsored
section over here and this was more or
less for
when we were doing sponsors but in my
book here i don't actually
have any sponsors so instead what i
might do
is turn this into testimonials uh here
i'll also put in a small description so
maybe
what other people are saying
and instead of having say all these
boxes we might reduce this down to
just a couple so here i'm gonna just
have maybe
one here that spans four columns one
here that spans
four columns and one here that spans
four columns
for each one of these we might put in
some text and we might also change the
background color for this
so for the background color i might do
the blue here just so that it stands out
a bit more
and for the text i might set both of
these as white
so that they also stand out nicely we'll
also make sure that we center this
because right now it's a little bit
off-center
but that's looking much better then for
these items here i'm just going to
select them to have a white background
and we can put our testimonial quotes
inside of there
we're still aligning to our column
design here but we're just
repurposing the content based of what
we're going to put in here
i've got a few different bits of
testimonials that i'd like to put in
so let's actually grab our text tool
over here
and put in a small bit of text here i'm
going to reduce the font size here to
about 18 pixels
and we'll also do the opacity to about
66
and finally we'll just center this over
here
the first testimonial that we have here
is from traversing media from brad
so i'm just gonna put this in just below
and make it bold so that we can see what
he's been saying we've got
two more testimonials which i'm going to
put in
and one is here from
web dev simplified so i'm just going to
copy over
these two and we're going to reuse them
as we need so let's just paste them here
and here let's also move them up a
little bit just so that they all
align about 15 to 20 pixels from the top
and let's copy over this content over
here
so that's nice i've got a little bit too
much text there so i'm going to reduce
that just a tad
and let's put in web dev simplified in
here
and for our last we've got a guy here
called deved
and dev ed also had some nice things to
say so we'll paste that in here
and that should be it for our
testimonials
and finally we've got our site map here
now this doesn't change
too much i'm just going to make this
that same
dark color that we were using here in
our header content
and we're going to copy over our logo
that we had
and replace the one over here with this
one over here
great i don't really have a
phone or email just yet but the rest of
our content is still
mostly the same so i'm just gonna
copy it across and move it up a little
bit just so that it
fits in nicely so there it is
and i think that's about it we don't
really have to
change our footer here with this
copyright and this
finishes up our design now that the
desktop version is done we can take a
look at creating a mobile version for
this website
to do this we're going to select the
frame and we're going to select an
iphone over here on the right
i'm just going to expand this out to
the bottom over here and we can start
filling it out with content
the first thing we'll do is probably
grab the hero section and paste it in
here
the problem with this hero section right
now is that
we're actually utilizing too much width
and height
i might actually reduce the height here
just a tad so it's about the same as
before
and i'm also going to redu remove the
slider
the content in here also doesn't fit in
very nicely right now
we could probably make it smaller so for
this description here
i might just change it to 24 pixels
and for this one over here maybe to 48
pixels and we'll break the line on both
of them
that way we can see them here we could
also center them
and that way they might look a little
bit better and finally we can copy over
this
image and also make it a little bit
smaller and just place it in below
so that seems to look pretty good we
also have our logo which we can copy
across
and like all mobile websites they also
need a bit of a hamburger menu
and a hamburger menu is pretty simple
it's just three lines so
let's actually create three white lines
here at the top
left and this can later expand out to
our mobile menu so i'm just gonna
copy paste this across a few times and
we should see it pop up
let's grab one here one here we'll give
it just
a little bit of spacing and let's do the
same amount of spacing for this line
and there's our mobile menu nice and
simple to do i'm just going to move this
here to the top left
and the header section is more or less
done now
let's take a look at doing this uh about
section
so like previous we can just copy across
some of the content but in this case i'm
going to copy over the text first with
this read more button
and i'm just going to paste it in here
we're going to reduce the font sizes
again
so here i'll do 48 pixels this one here
can be
24 pixels and this one here can possibly
be 18 pixels
we'll collapse down the width for each
one of those so they might break the
line a little bit
but we'll also get a little bit of
padding here on the left and right and
that seems to fit in quite nicely
the only other thing i want to do is
change this uh
this read more button
and in this case i might want to make it
smaller and to do that i'm going to
scale it just a tad down here
also since we're centering most things
i'm going to center this
as well and all of that looks good
besides the title here which we need to
expand out a little bit
this read more also it doesn't seem to
be centered very well so i'm just going
to
manually center that and there we go so
we've got our learn
more content looking pretty good over
here
i'll finally copy across this image that
we had
and for this image i'm also going to
make it a little bit smaller by scaling
it down here
and just moving it below our section so
now it's nice and centered
and we can move on to the next part of
our website which is the testimonials
one thing to note is that each one of
these sections
might sometimes stay the same height or
sometimes get a little bit bigger
depending on how many columns and how
much content you
have in there but it shouldn't matter
too much as long as it's useful on the
mobile version
for the testimonials i'm going to copy
over the whole item here
but since there's so much i might
actually just copy it bit by
bit so first let's copy over this
background and
place it in here and right now it
is not appearing because it's not in the
right place i'm not sure where it's gone
here
so here's the background and here
is our iphone and what i want to be able
to do is
copy this background right in here and
move it in
there we go that looks much better now
so
for this testimonial section
let's copy over these titles and we'll
paste them in here
once again we'll have to reduce the font
size so here i'll do
48 pixels for the testimonial i'll
center it
and this one here i'll do 24 pixels and
i'll center that as well
and then we can just copy them over
these ones actually could
probably fit in nicely as they are now
so i'm going to copy over this section
here
and we'll paste it in with a little bit
of padding from the left and the right
and make it a little bit taller and then
we can just copy over the text here
we almost don't need to even change that
that seems to fit in
perfectly as it is now we could
reduce it just to one testimonial but in
this case i want to keep all three so
i'm just gonna
copy this across and give it some margin
here from the top
let's copy our second testimonial in
here and our third
and i forgot to keep the the person here
so let's copy that across one more time
and that is definitely not seeming to
copy across properly i'm not sure what's
going on there
uh it's gone a bit wonky
let's try that one more time so i'm just
gonna
grab it over here copy it down and grab
this one
and copy it across and there we go
let's close off this section here give
it a little bit of padding from the bot
bottom and finally we just need to do
our footer design now
so for our footer we could copy across
the whole section
because we need the contact us the form
the site map
and the logo so let's do that we'll need
to make this whole section
a bit longer to be able to fit it all in
and to do this now we simply copy across
each one of these elements across
or even reuse some of the elements we
have and update the
colors that we have on them so in this
case i'm just going to create the
rectangle over here to start
off at this level and then i'm just
going to copy over each one of these
columns which
is easy enough then when we copy it
across we'll see that
it just should fit in nicely some things
we might need to adjust so
for example with the inputs i would
normally recommend them to have a full
width
and all of these texts again i would say
would be
recommended to update their sizing just
so that they're all consistent and
everything updates accordingly
so there's our contact us let's copy
over our sitemap we'll put this one
below
i'm just going to reduce the size on
that one
as well and finally
here we've got our about site map
section and our logo which we can paste
here below and our phone
and email which i'm just going to copy
across over here
so that's more or less all of this done
uh we just have our copyright section
here at the very
end which we can copy across
and let's put this into our design over
here
just at the very very bottom
and let's copy over this one and we can
make this font size a little bit smaller
as well
and that should almost fit in there it
probably
needs to break a line and have a little
bit more room
but it seems to have fit in there just
okay
i'm going to actually make it a little
bit bigger so to do that let's select
the
frame here at the top let's make the
frame a little bit bigger
and then that'll give us just enough
room there for the copyright section to
fit in
great so that's the mobile version done
and as you can see it's followed more or
less the same principles here
the only other thing is sometimes when
we increase the
size of our page some of these elements
might go a bit
weird uh and this is just a figma thing
so i'm just gonna
fix that up and i think that's more or
less that done
i hope you guys enjoyed this video this
figma design i'm gonna share in the
description below so you guys can have a
look at it
and you can do your own iterations of it
based on the initial
design that we had as well it's really
fun and simple to play with and it gives
you an example of how we can create a
mock-up
really quickly based from a simple ui
prototype
in the next video we might take a look
at maybe building this out using html
and css
or even putting it into a framework like
react or
maybe even wordpress but hopefully this
is an introduction to show you just how
important it is to be able to do
design in simple steps